Gregg's in Oklahoma City hi Greg how are
you I'm doing pretty well thanks Dave I
really appreciate you taking my call sir
what's up where to start
I'm 42 years old and I actually in the
CEO business I'm lucky enough to open it
nine years ago and we're doing pretty
well the problem is I really don't have
anything to show for it
and I really need advice on how to save
I have two children I have a 16 year old
daughter and the 12 year old son yam a
16 year old will be going to college for
priests and she's a junior and I'm
pretty much scared to death right now I
mean the problem is we make plenty of
money coming in I have a spouse that has
a spending problem and I've actually had
to put some money away you know just for
mortgages basically if it shows up in
the bank account is like a race to zero
anytime I deposit check it's a race to
zero and that's not the way I was
brought up and that's not okay I've run
my business and so what are you
preparing
you own this business right idea and how
much were you making here I make right
at $260,000 year taxable income taxable
income you have nothing
I pretty much I mean I have a home I
have some cars you know but as far as
retirement goes I really don't know much
III don't and scares me to death I mean
what's not much I mean you got ten
thousand or a hundred thousand well I
have about $50,000 cash and that I the
is you get more that you know otherwise
yes no you know and the problem with
that is that actually goes to my
mortgage because if the money is in the
bank every time
cause of my paycheck mm-hmm which you
know I don't know it's like $89 week
later it's a race to the earth if if I
actually left that money in there for
that month and and went to pay more the
money wouldn't be there for the mortgage
at the end of the month yeah so one of
the other hundred and sixty thousand
dollars a year because eighteen hundred
dollars a week is less than a hundred a
year say that again I'm sorry you said
you made two hundred sixty thousand but
eighteen hundred dollars a week is only
a hundred thousand well right if I earn
ten thousand that's my base salary but
we do get shareholder distributions
throughout the year and one of those go
into that same account bonuses and you
know that's those that money actually
goes into the savings a lot and then
some do go into the checking account so
where's all right cool yeah I try to
pull the majority of it out there has
all of that gone actually in a deposit
box how much is in the deposit box right
at $50,000 that's not even close we're
talking about a ha sixty a year Oh No
well that's what I'm saying
the money it's a race to zero okay so
when you shouldn't talking to her about
this that your lives are completely out
of control and you're spending like
you're freakin in Congress what did she
sadly she she actually feels really bad
about it
she knows that it's wrong she cries we
had the you know look like come to Jesus
talk you know I'm gonna change just give
me a cash and you know allowance you
tried that
hold it you know the C is 43 how long
have you been married we've been
together since 94 and we were married in
98 so is she seeing a counselor not for
this but she needs to or depression she
needs to Oh
bipolar uh no she you know it could be
it she has not been diagnosed with
bipolar as well this is a manic behavior
it's it's absolutely insane because my
daughter luckily and here's the thing
and this is her thinking and from what
she says my daughter is very bright as a
matter of fact she turned us on to Dave
Ramsey and stop a [ __ ] to stop okay
here's the thing okay we have to decide
if your wife is being a doofus or if she
has emotional mental issues if she's
seeing a counselor for legitimate
depression and it's possible she's manic
that would explain this in which case
you have to treat her as if she's got a
mental issue which she does and I mean
she just has no access to money at all
just take her take her off the account
just open a new account you manage the
money because your wife is broken right
now
and you care for her as if she's got a
drug addiction or as if she's got cancer
or is if she's got by going and you take
care of her until she walks through the
healing process and is able to step back
in and make an adult like emotional
contribution to this conversation but
you're asking someone who's broken to
carry a load they can't carry when you
dump that money into that account right
so just take it away from her and it's
not to punish her it's because she can't
you know she's doing cocaine we're not
gonna supply it right okay because this
is adding to her depression when she's
out of control like that she wakes up
with a depression hangover after this is
more depressed because she's more out of
control oh it's you know when I get my
bank statement it horizon or not rising
but I don't care on Amazon I don't care
it I don't care what you've been doing
is not working you make 260 thousand
dollars a year you have nothing to show
for it there's a big freakin hole in the
bucket quit using the bucket take the
bucket away just honey I love you and
when you need some money you come to me
and I will give you some money for
whatever it is you're working on but
you're off of all accounts until we get
your mental illness addressed right
because that's where she is dude yeah
it's easier said than done
that's not I must not sit down with her
in your counselor so now with her
counselor because you're adding to her
depression
where I am you're part of a problem
you're right and so you're counseling it
exactly the counselor well you're making
it worse because she be it's more
depressed because she feels like a
doofus and so you need to know the
counselor and just go baby you're taking
you off of everything and if you don't
like that let's go see a marriage
counselor and the marriage counselor
tell her the same thing if they got a
brain in their head no exactly I just
like she's sabotaging everything that
we've worked for
no she she's cut this cuz she's sick
buddy you're I you can't you can't
simultaneously treat her like she's got
a mental illness and then on the other
side come over here and act like she's a
petulant teenager now if she's a
petulant teenager rationally I
understand it's not a rational
transaction if that's what's going on
and then if it is a rational transaction
then we've just got a maturity princess
issue but that's not nothing you've said
this conversation indicates that so love
her enough love her well take take this
responsibility off of her
she has no access to money as if she's
doing cocaine starting today and the
only access she gives us you lovingly
hand out little bits and then you manage
this household for the good of your
future and your wife's future called
retirement and they go to your kids
future you make a ton of money and you
take control of this you're the CEO of
your house to my man you can do this if
you need some more help you call me back
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you